το ταίδουλεύει εδώ και μήνες για αυτόν ενδεχόμενον αα επαρχον σενάρια στο τραπέζι τα οποία
μελετόνται για να δούμε πως θα περάσουμε το γαλοκα και τα οποία συμεχώσανα προσαρμόζονται αυτόν
το οποίον χρειαζόμαστε και αυτή την προσπάθεια δεν είμαστε μόνιμας για να παιτύχυμε να συνεχσουμε
να δίνουμε το εκατόν της εκατό που δεν είναι εύκολον αλλά συνεχίζουμε την προσπάθεια το
πρώτο είναι να μειώσουμε τις απόλιας είναι για αυτό των λόγον που ζητήσαμεμε δική ουμας
πρωτοβουλία που τους εοά να μας καταθέσουν και να μας δώσουν τα προβληγματικάδείχτια για να
διμειουργήσουμε ένα σχέδιον για να τους βοηθήσουμε τα δείκτια που έχουν υπό την ευθύνη τους
να τα διορθώσουν το δεύτερο είναι ότι δουλεύουμε για να δώσουμε στον ιδιωτικών τομε στα
ξεανοδοχία μας μια ενίσχυση για να μπορέσειυ να τοποθετήσει διοτικές αφαλαδώσεις από το εύριο μι
από τις ικόσι οκτοδεράσεις ήταν η τοποθέτηση διωτικόν αφαλά τόσο για σκοπούς ιδρεύσεις στα ξενοδοχία
δεν υπήρχει νι αντααποκρίση που θέλαμε τώρα το δουλεύουμε περισσότερο απλοποιούμε γι περισσότερο τις διαδικασίες
μας για να τους βοηθήσουμε και φυσικά είναι αυτό που ζητάμε και από τον κόσμο
να σταματήσει να κάνεις πατάλες μία βόλτα στη γειτονιας σας θα σας κάνει να κατανοήσεται
ότι δυστυχώς ελάχιστι έχουν καταλάβει το πού βρισκόμαστε πραγματικά είναι αν επίτρεπτον αυτόν το φαινόμενον
το βλέπουμε καθημερινά εγώ έχω κοραστεί να γανο παρατηρήσεις όχ κουραστεί να μηλώ με τους
με τους προέδρους το νεοάπολύ από τους εοποίους έτσι τρέχουν να δίνουν γι αυτή τα
πρόστημα αλλά νομίζονται αυτό είναι θέμα να αντίληψης και πρέπει να σταματήσει το νερών είναι
ένα ανα γαθόν που ανοίκησεολούσουμας και για να συνεχίσουμε να το θεωρούμε δεδομένω όπως εκάναμε
μέχρι σημερα θα πρέπει προτήστος να τος